Es gibt böse Menschen.
Ich musste das
über mich ergehen lassen.
Es war Horror.
Sie wurden entrechtet,
erniedrigt und missbraucht.
Diese Ungerechtigkeit
wollte ich nicht stehen lassen.
Sie hat mich beschäftigt.
Eine Initiative zwang die Politik,
sich mit dem Leid der Heim-
und Verdingkinder zu befassen.
Wegschauen ist auch eine Handlung.
Das Parlament
stimmte einem Solidaritätsbeitrag
von 25'000 Fr. pro Opfer zu.
Ende gut, alles gut?
Ich fühle mich
aufs Gröbste verarscht.
Die seelischen Narben bleiben.
Gott hat seinen Job nicht gemacht.
Wie kann man Kinder
in einer Kirche missbrauchen?
Das ist doch verrückt. Ich bin 64,
aber es geht mir immer noch nahe.
Man muss im Leben vergeben können.
Es wird einfacher,
wenn man vergeben kann.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Das Unheil nimmt
in Thalwil am Zürichsee seinen Lauf.
Mario Delfino erinnert sich
an einen unbeschwerten Lebensanfang
in einem Waisenhaus in Norditalien.
Dann adoptiert ihn ein
kinderloses Ehepaar aus der Schweiz.
Es sieht immer noch gleich aus
wie 1960, als ich gekommen bin.
Am 1. April 1960.
Da kam ich hierher.
Und ...
Ja.
Für mich ist es
keine schöne Erinnerung.
Nein, das ist ...
Ich war fünf.
Ich lebte drei Jahre lang in Angst.
In diesem Häuschen dort.
Oben rechts war mein Zimmer.
Sein Zimmer ist ein Gefängnis.
Ein Gefängnis
mit Sicht auf den Zürichsee.
Der Fünfjährige
wird stundenlang eingesperrt.
Er schaut aus dem Fenster
und ist fasziniert.
Wasser und Bewegung.
Es kam immer wieder ein Schiff,
Stadt Zürich, Stadt Rapperswil,
und wie sie alle hiessen.
Der Traum
auf einem solchen Schiff zu sein
mit der richtigen Mama,
dem richtigen Papa.
Lachen, es schön haben,
etwas zu essen.
In die Weite gehen.
Ins Leben hinaus.
Getragen werden, getragen werden
von der Wärme.
Ohne Druck. Das Wasser.
Ich liebe das Wasser heute noch.
* Möwenkreischen *
Es sind kleine Lichtblicke
in seinem dunklen Leben.
Ich fühlte eine grosse Einsamkeit.
Ja.
Ich konnte die Sprache nicht,
neues Haus, neue Gerüche, neu ...
Daran erinnere ich mich gut.
Und fremd. Alles fremd.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
furchtbar allein zu sein.
* Beklemmende, flirrende Klänge *
Als die Adoptivmutter merkt,
dass der eingesperrte Bub
gerne aus dem Fenster schaut,
nimmt sie ihm auch das.
Als wir das Fenster zugemalt haben,
ist für mich eine Welt
zusammengebrochen.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Wer versteht schon so was?
Warum macht man so etwas?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich glaube aus Bosheit.
Es gibt böse Menschen.
Die gibt es. Ich bin ein sehr
positiver Mensch und mag Menschen.
Aber es gibt böse Menschen.
Ja. Sie war böse.
Auch das ist Gewalt.
Das geht gar nicht. Es ist verrückt.
Jetzt bin ich ein erwachsener Mann.
Und es berührt mich immer noch.
Ja.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Schritte, Knarzen *
Wenn ich die Treppengeräusche hörte,
brachte ich das immer mit ...
... etwas Schlechtem, Bösem
in Verbindung.
* Schritte, Knarzen *
Wenn die Adoptivmutter kommt,
versteckt er sich.
* Schweres Atmen *
Wenn man
keine seelische Wärme bekommt,
nimmt man sich eine Wolldecke.
Dann fühlte ich mich unsichtbar.
Unsichtbar und geborgen.
Es ist ähnlich wie hier.
Etwas ganz nahe am Kopf.
Ich entscheide,
es über mich zu ziehen.
Das war mein Schutz,
mein kleiner, seelischer Schutz.
So fühlte ich mich beschützt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
unter der Decke
weder gesehen noch gehört zu werden.
Schwarzenburg im Kanton Bern.
Hier lebt die 76-jährige
Berthy Schnegg mit ihrem Mann
und diversen Haustieren.
Neuerdings auch mit Katze Lily, die
von ihrer Mutter verstossen wurde.
Berthy Schnegg
zog sie mit der Flasche auf:
alle paar Stunden einen Schoppen.
Mich hat noch nie
ein Tier enttäuscht.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich schon als kleines Kind
eine kleine Tigerkatze
getragen habe.
Sie geben einem alles, die Tiere.
Ich mag sie sehr.
Ein Büsi,
das man so nahe bei sich haben kann,
ist das Schönste,
was man haben kann.
Manchmal sagen wir unseren Tieren,
sie seien lieb.
Während des Tages.
Ich habe als Kind nie gehört,
was Liebe heisst.
"Du bist lieb."
Das war für mich ein Fremdwort.
Zu dieser Zeit.
Lily, komm.
Komm.
Berthy Schnegg ist fünf Jahre alt,
als sich ihre Eltern scheiden lassen.
Sie und ihre vier Geschwister
werden auseinandergerissen.
Sie landet als Verdingkind
im Berner Oberland.
Wir haben nicht verstanden,
was passiert.
Das war für mich ein Schock.
Ich war sprachlos.
Ich habe auch
fast nichts zu diesen Leuten gesagt.
Ich wusste nicht, was passiert.
Sie sagten,
ich bräuchte keine Angst zu haben.
Das sei nun eben so.
Dann war es eben so.
Morgens beim Kämmen - ich hatte
schon damals dünne Haare, Zöpfe -
hat das geziept.
Sie schlug mit der Bürste
gegen meinen Kopf.
Ich solle stillhalten.
Ich bin jeweils
unter den Tisch gerutscht
und habe vor Angst
in die Hose gepinkelt.
Sie schlug mich mit der Bürste.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich dachte ...
Grüezi.
Mario Delfino trifft zufällig
eine Nachbarin seiner inzwischen
verstorbenen Adoptiveltern.
Wohnen Sie schon lange hier?
- 40 Jahre.
Sie hätten Sie
nicht adoptieren dürfen.
Sie hatten es nicht im Griff
mit den Kindern.
Sie war böse zu mir.
Ich hatte hier
keine schöne Kindheit.
Sie wollte Sie gar nicht. Sie machte
es nur wegen ihres Mannes.
Das wusste ich nicht.
- Das hat sie mir gesagt.
Das ist ...
- Das sagte sie mir.
Das höre ich zum ersten Mal.
Dass sie ...
Dass meine Adoptivmutter
ein Kind verloren hat.
Sie wollte mich nicht.
Der Vater schon.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ja.
Man hätte mich doch
im Waisenhaus lassen können.
Da wäre es mir besser ergangen.
Es ist verrückt.
Da trifft man nach all diesen Jahren
jemanden,
der diese Leute gekannt hat.
Ich hatte keine Infos
über diese Delfinos.
Gar nichts.
Man hat nicht darüber gesprochen.
Ja.
Er ist 13, als er mit zwei Kollegen
eine Geldkassette klaut,
über den eigenen Mut erschrickt
und sofort alles zurückgibt.
Trotzdem sind sich Jugendanwaltschaft
und Adoptivmutter einig:
Der Junge muss in ein Heim
für Schwererziehbare.
Das ist der Pausenplatz.
Ja.
Ich habe hier hinten gewartet.
Das Polizeiauto kam von da.
Hier habe ich mit meinen Freunden
die Pause verbracht.
Sie gingen zum Hauswart
und sagten: "Mario Delfino."
Er schaute nach und zeigte auf mich.
Sie legten mir Handschellen an
und luden mich in das Polizeiauto.
Sie fuhren mich direkt
von hier nach Knutwil.
* Düstere Klänge, Peitschenhiebe *
Ich wurde
mit einem Lederriemen geschlagen.
Das war schlimm.
Das werde ich nie vergessen.
Ich wurde geschlagen.
Ich musste die Hose runterlassen,
mich über ein Taburett legen.
Das hat gebrannt.
Ich wollte mich
mit den Händen schützen.
Sie haben sie aber weggezogen,
da gab es nichts zu schützen.
Er könne mir nicht genug geben.
Das sagte der Vater.
Der Pflegevater hat das gemacht,
nicht die Mutter.
Das war Horror.
Glauser, Jakob.
Sohn des Johannes und der Annemaria.
Pfeuti, Christian.
Verdingkinder, sog. Güterkinder -
zu Tausenden sind sie
in den Verdingbüchern registriert.
Kinder, die hart arbeiten mussten,
oft geschlagen wurden
und kaum Liebe erlebten.
Historikern wie Marco Leuenberger
fehlt es nicht an Quellen.
Wer es wissen wollte,
konnte es wissen:
Das Leid dieser Kinder
war nie ein Geheimnis.
Ledige Mütter, Geschiedene und
kinderreiche Familien gaben sie weg,
weil sie sie
nicht durchfüttern konnten.
Die Kinder wurden teilweise
sogar versteigert.
Bis 1850 ganz legal
auf Schweizer Märkten.
Mit dem Schweizer Fernsehen
besuchte Leuenberger 2004
das Kreisgericht Burgdorf.
Hier lagern Akten,
welche die brutalsten Übergriffe
und auch sexuellen Missbrauch
dokumentieren.
Z.B. am viereinhalbjährigen
Verdingbub Ernst,
der die Quälereien
1948 nur knapp überlebte.
"Am Gesäss und an den Beinen weist
es überall Mosen und Striemen auf,
ebenso am Gesicht."
"Am Kopf hat es eine Beule
wie ein Hühnerei."
"Der Doktor befürchtet sogar
einen Schädelbruch."
"Er glaubt, dass das Kind
mit einem Riemen, mit den Schuhen
oder mit Holz traktiert worden ist."
"Er möchte es nicht
von der Hand weisen,
dass das Kind an den Füssen genommen
und gegen die Wand
geworfen worden sei."
"Auf die Frage,
warum diese unerhörte Brutalität
dem Kinde gegenüber
angewendet worden sei,
bekommt man die Antwort,
es hätte das Bett genässt!"
Es gab auch viele Vergewaltigungs-
fälle von Mädchen und Buben.
Und man muss davon ausgehen,
dass die wenigsten Fälle
publik wurden.
Es wurde nur dann publik,
wenn die Kinder jemanden hatten,
der ihnen geglaubt hat,
oder wenn jemand zufällig dazukam,
der den Mut hatte,
das jemandem zu melden.
Historiker, linke Politiker und
Betroffene versuchten immer wieder,
eine umfassende Aufarbeitung
dieses dunklen Kapitels
der Schweizer Geschichte zu erwirken.
Und eine Wiedergutmachung.
Erfolglos.
Luzius Mader kennt das Dossier
bestens - die Gründe seien klar.
Es gibt Kreise,
die nichts davon wissen wollten.
Kreise,
die vielleicht betroffen waren.
Ich denke z.B. an die Kirche.
Ich denke ...
an bäuerliche Organisationen.
Sie hatten Kenntnis davon,
dass es Probleme gab im Heimwesen.
Dass es Probleme gab
bei den Verdingkindern.
Aber viele sind davon ausgegangen,
dass das Vergangenheit ist.
Es gab nur wenige Betroffene.
Zudem hatte man wichtigere Themen.
Man wollte nicht
die Büchse der Pandora öffnen
und in der Vergangenheit wühlen.
Diese Büchse der Pandora
wird erst 2010 langsam geöffnet:
durch die damalige Justizministerin
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf
im Frauengefängnis Hindelbank.
Im Bewusstsein, dass Vergangenes
nicht ungeschehen
gemacht werden kann,
möchte ich Sie im Namen des Bundes
in aller Form um Entschuldigung
dafür bitten,
dass Sie ohne Gerichtsurteil
zur Erziehung
administrativ versorgt wurden.
Das politische Kalkül dahinter: Sie
will einen Präzedenzfall schaffen.
Bei der administrativen Versorgung
hatte man seitens der Kirche
keine Probleme.
Man hatte keine Probleme
seitens der Bauern.
Die Bösewichte
waren klar aufseiten der Behörden,
die falsch entschieden haben.
Gleichzeitig hatte man das Gefühl,
relativ genau zu wissen, dass es ...
... eine geringe Anzahl Personen
betrifft,
die administrativ versorgt wurden.
Es dauert drei Jahre,
bis das Parlament nachzieht:
Die administrativ Versorgten
werden rehabilitiert.
Und eine unabhängige
Expertenkommission
soll die Vergangenheit
wissenschaftlich aufarbeiten.
Aber Geld fliesst keines.
Guido Fluri verfolgt die Debatte
vor Ort - und ist entsetzt.
Diese Ungerechtigkeit
wollte ich nicht stehen lassen.
Sie hat mich beschäftigt.
Ich ging vom Bundeshaus nach Hause
und konnte nicht schlafen.
Morgens um 3 Uhr
erlebte ich eine Initialzündung:
"Das kann es nicht sein."
"Wir müssen
eine Entscheidung treffen."
"Es muss eine Volksinitiative,
die Stimme des Volkes kommen,
die die Politik unter Druck setzt,
um diese Aufarbeitung
schneller voranzutreiben."
Guido Fluri engagiert sich schon
länger für Heim- und Verdingkinder.
Hier Aufnahmen
von einem Gedenkanlass,
den er im solothurnischen Mümliswil
organisierte.
Sein Engagement erklärt sich
mit persönlicher Betroffenheit:
Er ist der uneheliche Sohn
einer 16-jährigen Kellnerin
und wuchs teilweise in Heimen auf.
Trotz schwierigem Start ins Leben
brachte er es zu sehr viel Geld.
Damit kaufte er
das Heim in Mümliswil,
in dem er einst platziert war,
und machte daraus eine Gedenkstätte.
Ein Mahnmal für geschehenes Unrecht,
das nicht vergessen gehen soll -
Unrecht, das auch ihm angetan wurde.
Welche Übergriffe haben Sie erlebt?
Ich möchte nicht ins Detail gehen.
Es gab hier auch Fälle,
die nicht toll waren.
Das ist so.
Aber ich möchte nicht
ins Detail gehen.
Wurden Sie z.B. geschlagen?
Das ist eigentlich
nichts Aussergewöhnliches.
Gewalt an Kindern
ist auch in der heutigen Zeit
nichts Aussergewöhnliches.
Es gibt nach wie vor
Gewalt an Kindern, häusliche Gewalt.
Wir waren in einem solchen Zimmer.
Fluri hat es
dank Immobiliengeschäften
aus dem Nichts zu mehreren Hundert
Millionen Franken gebracht -
und ist willens, damit etwas zu
bewegen für Heim- und Verdingkinder.
Inzwischen ist Simonetta Sommaruga
Justizministerin.
Nach dem Präzedenzfall,
den ihre Vorgängerin Widmer-Schlumpf
geschaffen hat,
will sie nun eine Aufarbeitung
für alle Opfergruppen.
Dieser Gedenkanlass
ist kein Abschluss,
sondern der Anfang
einer umfassenden Auseinandersetzung
mit einem dunklen Kapitel
der Schweizer Sozialgeschichte.
Es geht um uns alle.
Denn wegschauen
ist auch eine Handlung.
Deshalb soll dieser Tag heute
auch ein Bekenntnis sein.
Ein Bekenntnis zum Hinschauen
und ein Aufruf
gegen das Verdrängen und Vergessen.
Darüber hinaus
stellen sich finanzielle
und möglicherweise
auch noch weitere Fragen.
Ich habe deshalb einen Delegierten
für die Opfer von fürsorgerischen
Zwangsmassnahmen ernannt:
Herr alt Ständerat
Hansruedi Stadler.
Das ist neu:
Eine Bundesrätin spricht von Geld.
Und sie schafft einen runden Tisch.
Dieser runde Tisch ...
... hat in einer ersten Phase
entscheidend gewirkt,
um das notwendige Vertrauen
zwischen allen Involvierten
und Interessierten zu schaffen.
Das war ein wichtiger Schritt.
Der runde Tisch hat schon bald
einen neuen Chef: Luzius Mader.
Er soll eine umfassende Aufarbeitung
anstossen
und Massnahmenvorschläge erarbeiten -
zusammen mit Betroffenen,
Behörden, Kirchen und Bauernverband.
Knutwil im Kanton Luzern.
Als Mario Delfino 1968
im Alter von 13 Jahren hierherkommt,
ist es ein Heim für Schwererziehbare,
religiös geführt von Ordensmännern.
Delfino wird auf unbestimmte Zeit
eingewiesen.
Ihm werden zuerst
die Haare geschoren.
Dann beginnt ein jahrelanger
Albtraum - Tag für Tag aufs Neue.
Die Erinnerungen sind nicht lustig.
Wenn ich Schläge eingefangen habe,
war das hier das Waschbecken,
wo wir uns das Blut
abgewaschen haben.
Man hatte permanent Angst,
wenn der Lehrer mit dem Schlagstock
rumspaziert ist
oder uns mit dem Handrücken
ins Gesicht geschlagen hat.
Er hat nicht normal geschlagen,
sondern immer ins Gesicht.
Manchmal hat er die Seiten
hochgezogen, bis wir geblutet haben.
Wenn die anderen Kinder
Ferien hatten,
sind sie hier nach Hause gelaufen.
Das war der Weg der Freiheit.
Wir dachten immer:
"Wenn man vom Bauernhof weg ist,
ist man frei."
Ich hatte keine Hoffnung.
Wenn ich geschlagen wurde,
dachte ich oft:
"Hoffentlich
schlagen sie mich richtig."
"So fest, dass ich tot bin.
Dann bin ich frei."
Es ist endlos. Endlos schlimm.
Hm.
Heute werden in Knutwil zivil-
und strafrechtliche Massnahmen
für stark verhaltensauffällige
Jugendliche umgesetzt.
In völlig neuem Geist.
Unter weltlicher Führung.
Die Gebäude von damals wurden
renoviert, aber sie stehen noch.
Jede Nacht
ist jemand hin- und hergelaufen.
Man hörte die Schritte.
* Schweres Atmen, Schritte *
Der seelische Schutz
unter der Decke -
nichts hören und nichts sehen.
Wenn man die Decke wegnahm,
um Luft zu schnappen,
hörte man die anderen Kinder weinen.
Schluchzen und so. Ja.
Was macht man?
Man ist auch traurig. Ja.
Eines Abends ...
... waren wir auch im Zimmer
unter der Wolldecke.
Wir wurden angetippt.
Es wurde kein Name gesagt,
sondern "119."
Ich wusste nicht, was das ist.
Ich sagte: "Ja?"
Er sagte: "Kommst du schnell raus?"
119 - das ist Mario Delfinos
Anstaltsnummer.
Das ist der schlimmste Horrorgang
meines Lebens.
Hier waren früher Waschbecken.
Das waren unsere Zimmer.
Und ...
Hier kam der Bruder raus.
Mit dem Rosenkranz.
Er lief hier auf und ab.
Wir mussten uns hier aufstellen.
Wir mussten das Pyjama ausziehen.
* Bedrohliche, flirrende Klänge *
Dann begann er, dich anzufassen.
Wir Kinder waren erstarrt vor Angst.
Wir kannten das nicht.
Wir wusste nicht,
was Sexualität ist.
Ich wurde sprachlos.
Ich habe nichts gesagt,
aber gepinkelt - aus Angst.
Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Angst ... das ist etwas Schlimmes.
Er schlug mich. Ich musste
meine Unterhose ausziehen.
Ich musste den Urin aufwischen,
die Unterhose wieder anziehen.
Wer macht so etwas?
Nur schon das ...
Das ist, wie soll ich sagen,
entwürdigend.
* Bedrohliche, flirrende Klänge *
Einer muss jeweils
mit dem Bruder aufs Zimmer.
Berthy Schnegg
plagen die Erinnerungen
an ihre zwei "Verdingbrüder".
Einer ist zehn Jahre älter als sie,
der andere 14 Jahre älter.
Es gab einen guten und einen bösen.
Der Ältere war der böse.
Er hat mich oft gepiesackt.
Er hat mich physisch und psychisch
kaputtgemacht.
Beim Heuen sagte er mir:
"Jetzt säuft sie schon wieder
wie eine Kuh."
Er hat mir das Trinken vergönnt
beim Arbeiten.
Als ich gemerkt habe,
dass sie mich nicht mögen,
ging ich in den Stall.
Ich legte mich zwischen die Ziegen
und schlief mit dem Kopf
auf der Ziege ein.
Sie haben mich gesucht,
das kam oft vor.
Ich suchte im Stall
Schutz und Wärme.
Das haben Sie
von den Tieren bekommen?- Ja.
Sie haben mich nicht geschlagen.
Sie sagten keine bösen Dinge.
Man konnte einfach bei ihnen sein.
Die Kitze sind mir jeweils
nachgerannt.
Eines schönen Tages hiess es:
"Mädchen, du musst
mit dem Kitz zum Metzger."
Das Kitz weinte, ich weinte.
Das vergesse ich nie.
Man kann doch einem Kind
nicht sagen,
es müsse mit dem Kitz zum Metzger.
Sie haben mir solche ...
Nein, nein ...
Das kann man nicht machen.
Sie haben es gemacht. Unmöglich.
In Knutwil trifft Mario Delfino
Gilbert. Sie werden beste Freunde.
Plötzlich hörte ich
einen dumpfen Schlag.
* Dumpfer Schlag *
Ich sah Gilbert hängen.
Ich weiss nicht ... Ich vermute,
er hat das Genick gebrochen
durch das harte Runterspringen. Ich
weiss nicht, wie er es gemacht hat.
Ich habe das Bild von ihm vor mir,
wie er hängt.
So.
Ja. Mit den Armen hängend. So ...
Eine Körperpose,
der man die Wehrlosigkeit ansieht.
Wie jemand ... der sich ergibt.
Schlimm ... Mist.
Das Erhängen ist das eine.
Aber warum?
Stell dir vor.
Das ist doch verrückt. Ich bin 64,
aber es geht mir immer noch nahe.
Bundesrätin Sommaruga
hat mit Luzius Mader
einen Mann an der Spitze
des runden Tisches,
der sowohl Verwaltung
als auch Parlament bestens kennt.
Die politischen Mehrheiten
sind allerdings gegen sie.
Die Aufarbeitung droht
auf halbem Wege stecken zu bleiben.
Bis Guido Fluri auftaucht.
Flankiert von furrerhugi, der
potentesten Berner Lobbying-Firma,
beginnt er, für seine sog. Wieder-
gutmachungs-Initiative zu weibeln.
Diese will
eine umfassende Aufarbeitung,
eine Entschuldigung und Geld.
Guido Fluri
hatte eine entscheidende Rolle.
Ihm ist gelungen,
die verschiedenen Opfervertreter
hinter sich zu bringen.
Er hat rasch gemerkt,
dass man eine Lösung anstreben muss,
bei der es nicht um Verurteilung
oder Aburteilungen
von einzelnen Akteuren geht.
Ich wusste, dass ich nicht
die Schuldfrage
ins Zentrum stellen darf.
Das wurde im Vorfeld
immer falsch gemacht.
Es wurde mit dem Wallholz
geschwungen.
Es wurde nach Sühne gelechzt.
Das ist falsch.
Wir hätten die emotionale Tragweite
aufzeigen müssen,
wie diese Menschen gelitten haben.
Fluri kennt die Berner Verhältnisse
kaum, lernt aber schnell.
Ich begrüsse noch kurz
Herrn Darbellay.
Ja, ist gut.
Grüezi, Herr Darbellay. Fluri.
Wir haben uns am Laureus
kennengelernt.
Ah ja.- Vielleicht
haben Sie nachher kurz Zeit?
Ja, nachher.
Grüezi, Herr Landolt. Darf ich Ihnen
nachher Guido Fluri vorstellen?
Machen wir das nachher.
Hoi.
- Hoi, alles im Griff?
Hast du nachher kurz Zeit für mich?
- Eine Sekunde.
Ist Ihnen diese Welt sympathisch,
Herr Fluri?- Wie?
Ob Ihnen diese Welt sympathisch sei.
- Es ist hektisch.
Man muss die einzelnen Personen
für unsere Initiative befragen.
Hinter den Kulissen wird gemauschelt.
Wie ist Ihr Eindruck?
Politische Spiele ...
- Das gehört dazu.
Ich nenne das Konsensfindung.
Das ist schön ausgedrückt.
- Ja.
Grüezi, Frau Fehr.
- Grüezi, Herr Fluri.
Fluri muss versuchen,
ein ursprünglich linkes Anliegen
mehrheitsfähig zu machen.
Sie haben heute
einen grossen Arbeitstag.
Ja, ja.
Ich werde eingeführt
in die politische ...
Fluri wirkt im Vordergrund
und baut medialen Druck auf.
Das kommt Bundesrätin Sommaruga
und der Verwaltung sehr gelegen.
Man kooperiert.
Diesen Betrag
haben wir noch nicht definiert.
Gewisse Verhältnismässigkeiten ...
- Sie müssen es spüren.
Es gelingt,
die Mehrheitsverhältnisse zu drehen.
Die Geldfrage ist dabei zentral:
Wenn Fluri eine Mehrheit will,
darf er nicht zu viel fordern.
Die entscheidenden Treffen,
auch mit Luzius Mader
und der Verwaltung,
passieren abseits von Kameras.
Aus meiner Sicht war das
eine Art von Zusammenarbeit,
die eher ungewöhnlich war.
In der Intensität, die sie hatte.
Es war aber auch
eine ausserordentliche Situation.
Diese Zusammenarbeit wurde getragen
von einem gemeinsamen Willen,
etwas zu erreichen.
Darum konnten Kompromisse
geschaffen werden.
Betroffene haben Unterschriften
für die Wiedergutmachungs-Initiative
gesammelt.
Die meisten lässt Fluri
allerdings durch Profis sammeln.
Dafür und für PR und Lobbying
gibt er insgesamt 5 Mio. Fr. aus.
Der Druck auf die Politik
steigt nun entscheidend.
Zudem hat er Parlamentarier aus allen
Parteien für sein Komitee gewonnen
und die meisten Medien
auf seiner Seite.
Dafür erntet er
vordergründig Applaus.
* Applaus *
Hinter den Kulissen
brodelt es allerdings gewaltig.
Die zentrale Streitfrage:
Wie viel Geld bekommen die Opfer?
Im Nachhinein muss man sagen,
war es anspruchsvoller,
die eigenen Reihen zusammenzuhalten
als der politische Prozess
an und für sich.
Das muss man sagen.
Ich war immer dazwischen,
was sehr viel Kraft gekostet hat.
* Bedrohliche, flirrende Klänge *
Die Situation im Berner Oberland
spitzt sich zu,
als Berthy Schnegg
in die Pubertät kommt.
Ihr "böser" Verdingbruder
ist inzwischen fast 30.
Zunächst bedrängt und betatscht
er sie.
Eines Nachts geht er weiter.
Er hat mich geweckt.
Wie kam er in Ihr Zimmer?
- Er kam zum Fenster rein.
Ich habe im Erdgeschoss
in der Küchenstube geschlafen.
Er kam rein.
Ich wusste nicht, was er wollte.
"Was will er bei mir?"
Er sagte: "Rutsch ein Stück,
ich möchte zu dir."
Ich fragte:
"Warum willst du zu mir?"
"Du bist eine Liebe,
ich mag dich doch."
Ich sagte, dass er mich
normalerweise doch dreckig behandle.
Das wolle ich nicht.
Ich fand das sehr komisch
und dachte:
"Das muss ich
über mich ergehen lassen."
"Du darfst niemandem etwas sagen,
sonst verprügle ich dich."
Was war das Schlimmste für Sie
in Ihrer Jugend?
Dass mir vorgeworfen wurde ...
... ich müsse mich ...
... bei ihnen bedanken,
dass sie zu mir schauen.
Es war nicht meine Schuld.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mario Delfino
ministrierte in Knutwil.
Heute ist die Kirche
ein gastronomisches Eventlokal.
Früher wurde er hier
vom Dorfpfarrer missbraucht.
Ich musste hier in der Mitte
auf einem Lineal knien.
Es gab hier einen Gang.
Links und rechts waren Bänke.
Ich musste auf dem Holzlineal knien.
Das war schmerzhaft. Zur Strafe
musste ich den Rosenkranz beten.
Ja. So pervers
waren die Menschen hier damals.
Zur Strafe wofür?
Ja, dass ich ihn nicht ...
... zufriedenstellen konnte.
So.
Gott hat seinen Job nicht gemacht.
Wie kann man Kinder
in einer Kirche missbrauchen?
Das geht doch nicht.
Wenn es einen Gott gibt, könnte er
doch einen Blitz einschlagen lassen.
Er könnte doch etwas tun,
aber es passiert einfach nichts.
Es sind Kinder.
Und derselbe Pfarrer
geht die Kanzel hoch
und betet um Nächstenliebe
und Vergebung und alles zusammen.
Wie kann ich da abends schlafen?
Oder im späteren Leben
oder jetzt finden:
"Gott hat mich immer beschützt."
Ich weiss es nicht,
ich kann es nicht sagen.
Ich habe den Glauben verloren.
Das muss ich sagen.
* Düstere Musik *
Das Parlament ist nun am Zug.
Es liegt ein indirekter Gegen-
vorschlag zu Fluris Initiative vor:
Bundesrätin Sommaruga möchte,
dass sich die Schweiz entschuldigt,
umfassend aufarbeitet
und 300 Mio. Fr. zahlt.
Fluris Initiative
hat 500 Mio. gefordert.
Auf der Zielgeraden
wird neu ein Maximalbetrag fixiert:
25'000 Fr. pro Opfer.
Eine solche Belastung
habe ich noch nie in mir gespürt.
Insgesamt, vom Paket her.
Was wäre passiert,
wenn wir im Parlament diese Mehrheit
nicht bekommen hätten?
Was wäre dann passiert?
Ja.
Dann ... hätten wir
vors Volk gehen müssen.
Und wenn es dann
keine Mehrheit gegeben hätte?
Ja, dann ...
Das wäre ... Da hätte ich
die Verantwortung übernehmen müssen.
Das ist ganz klar.
Ich hätte mich verantwortlich
gefühlt und mich geschämt.
Dafür, dass es nicht geklappt hat.
Zuerst stimmt der Nationalrat dem
indirekten Gegenvorschlag klar zu,
später auch der Ständerat.
Bravo!
Dank ihm.
- Ja, danke schön.
Fluri akzeptiert
und zieht seine Initiative zurück.
Das ist für mich Ausdruck eines
sehr ausgeprägten Bewusstseins,
dass dieses Thema nun reif ist.
Und dass die Zeit eilt,
weil die meisten Betroffenen
inzwischen hochbetagt sind.
Das entsprechende Bundesgesetz
entsteht innert weniger Monate.
Rund 9'000 Gesuche
werden schliesslich bewilligt.
Ende gut, alles gut?
Andreas Jost findet: Nein.
Er ist selber Betroffener
und war Teil des runden Tisches.
Der Heimwerker und IV-Rentner sagt,
25'000 Fr. für seine traumatische
Jugend im Heim - ein schlechter Witz.
Ich fühle mich aufs
Gröbste verarscht. Aufs Gröbste.
Der wirtschaftliche Schaden,
der jedem Einzelnen von uns
entstanden ist,
sei es durch eine Ausbildung,
die man nicht machen konnte,
z.B. als Ingenieur,
Bauarbeiter oder als Sanitär ...
Man spricht bei jedem Betroffenen
von einem Millionenverlust,
der ihm dadurch entstanden ist.
Es war ein fauler Kompromiss.
Es war ein absolut
fauler Kompromiss.
Er will mehr -
eine lebenslange Opferrente.
Und nicht nur die einmaligen
25'000 Fr., die Fluri erwirkt hat.
Ich kenne sehr viele Betroffene,
für die Guido Fluri
unterdessen ein rotes Tuch ist.
Wäre viel mehr Geld zu holen gewesen?
Ich glaube, dass die Personen, die
Guido Fluri einen Vorwurf machen,
wenig berufen sind,
um die Erfolgschancen dieser Vorlage
begründet beurteilen zu können.
Glauben Sie mir,
80-90 % der Betroffenen
waren sehr, sehr dankbar, dass die
Anerkennung endlich gekommen ist.
Ich darf als erstem Redner nach mir
Herrn Jost das Wort übergeben.
Einer der letzten Akte
der Aufarbeitung:
Die Unabhängige Expertenkommission,
kurz UEK, hat geladen -
auch Andreas Jost.
Ich bin tief betroffen
über die vielen Menschen,
die glauben, mit dem
Solidaritätsbeitrag sei es getan.
Obwohl es deutlich sein sollte,
dass dieser keine Grundlage
darstellen kann,
um wenigstens unseren Lebensabend
in Würde
und ohne Existenzängste
verbringen zu können.
Dürfen wir die Aufarbeitung
als abgeschlossen erklären
oder sollten wir nicht eher
zur Überzeugung gelangen,
dass Letztere gerade erst
begonnen hat?
Danke.
Der Anlass hat Gewicht.
Die UEK wurde 2014
vom Bundesrat eingesetzt
und übergibt ihm 2019 ihren Bericht
samt Empfehlungen, u.a.:
eine Opferrente.
Ich war sehr konsterniert
an diesem Anlass,
dass die UEK
ihr Buch mit den Empfehlungen
auf die Vorarbeiten
einer Arbeitsgruppe abgestützt hat.
Diese wurde gebildet von den
fünf bis sechs lautesten Personen,
die Forderungen gestellt haben.
Da muss ich sagen:
Das finde ich schlicht falsch.
Der Vorwurf an Markus Notter
und seine UEK:
Sie hätten nur den notorisch
Unzufriedenen eine Plattform gegeben.
Liessen Sie sich instrumentalisieren
von einer kleinen Gruppe Querulanten?
Das finde ich
eine unerhörte Unterstellung.
Das muss ich sagen.
Die UEK war zusammengesetzt
aus hochkarätigen Wissenschaft-
lerinnen und Wissenschaftlern.
Sie hatten durchaus die Fähigkeit,
sich eine eigene Meinung zu bilden
und diesen Input zu diskutieren,
der von verschiedenen Seiten
gekommen ist.
Das empfinde ich als despektierlich.
Sowohl der UEK gegenüber
als auch den Betroffenen gegenüber
und den Opfern,
die durchaus vernünftige
Gesprächspartner waren
mit einsichtigen und vernünftigen
Forderungen, die sie gestellt haben.
Mir tun die Opfer leid.
Was mit den Empfehlungen
passiert ist, ist,
dass der Prozess
wieder eröffnet wurde.
Es wurden wieder Forderungen
in den Raum gestellt,
die nicht realisierbar sind.
Bei vielen Opfern, die froh waren,
dass der Prozess zu einem Ende kam,
zu einem guten Ende, und
die Befriedigung empfunden haben,
bricht das Ganze wieder auf.
Die paternalistische Pseudofürsorge,
die jetzt teils
an den Tag gelegt wird,
wenn man meint,
man könne den Betroffenen und Opfern
die Erkenntnis nicht zumuten,
dass der Staat nicht alles,
was sie fordern, auch erfüllt.
Damit kann ich nichts anfangen.
Diese Menschen
sind sehr selbstständig,
sehr selbstbewusst,
sie mussten auch eine Resilienz
an den Tag legen,
damit sie ihr Leben
überhaupt meistern konnten.
Ihnen muss man nicht sagen,
welche Forderungen sie stellen
und nicht stellen dürfen,
damit sie nicht enttäuscht sind.
Irgendwo finde ich das
eine seltsame Haltung.
Bonjour, welcome,
buenos dias, bon dia, buongiorno.
Guido Fluri will nun
eine europaweite Aufarbeitung
nach Schweizer Vorbild anstossen.
Das erste Treffen mit Opfervertretern
aus zehn Ländern
findet Corona-bedingt
virtuell statt.
Weitere Staaten
sollen umfassend aufarbeiten,
sich offiziell entschuldigen
und zahlen.
Wir haben hier
in der Schweiz gelernt,
dass man nur mit politischem Druck
eine Änderung erreichen kann.
Es braucht eine Kampagne,
die das Problem ins Zentrum rückt.
Guido Fluri - ein Ausnahmemensch.
Ein Mensch mit Herz.
Ich kenne ihn nicht so gut,
aber er hat innert kurzer Zeit
einfach gehandelt. Mit dem Herzen.
Klar auch mit finanziellen Mitteln,
aber Hut ab vor Menschen wie Guido.
Die 25'000 Fr. waren ein willkommener
Zustupf für Familie Delfino.
Viel wertvoller sei aber gewesen,
dass sie endlich offen
über alles geredet hätten.
Ich erinnere mich noch gut.
Wenn ich als Kind nicht gehorcht
oder Mist gebaut habe,
oder es zu Streit gekommen ist,
wurde er jeweils fuchsteufelswild.
Schwierigkeiten im Leben
haben ihn aufbrausen lassen.
Er war temperamentvoll.
Jetzt ist er ruhig geworden.
Das kann man schon sagen.
Ja, entspannter. Das spürt man.
Er ist ein grosser Schritt weiter.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass er das gemacht hat.
Er steht jetzt drüber.
Ich glaube, ich bin angekommen.
Ich bin glücklich und zufrieden
und angekommen.
Dank meiner Familie.
Das Beste kommt am Schluss.
Es ist wirklich so:
Ich bin glücklich und zufrieden.
Es ist gut.
Berthy Schnegg hat den Antrag
für den Solidaritätsbeitrag
zusammen mit ihrem Sohn Andreas
ausgefüllt.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich sollte Herrn Fluri noch
persönlich Danke sagen,
für das, was er für uns getan hat.
Das Wahrgenommenwerden
dieser Vergangenheit,
die schwierig war.
Das ist ein Teil der Verarbeitung,
die zuversichtlich stimmt
und guttut.
Meiner Mutter und uns als Familie.
Ich habe meinem Vater
und meiner Mutter vergeben.
Was sie an uns verfehlt haben.
Es waren Situationen,
die dazu geführt haben.
Wenn man Kinder hat,
kann man sie doch nicht einfach
weggeben und vergessen.
Du hast es super gemacht.
Aber eben.
Man muss im Leben vergeben können.
Es ist eine Erleichterung,
wenn man vergeben kann.
* Bedrückende Musik *
* Klicken *
Ich suche die Weite.
Die Weite, die Tiefe, das Wasser.
Die Weite.
Einfach nicht das Eingeengte.
Als Kind war ich in einer Schachtel.
Darum mag ich die Weite.
Für mich ist die Welt schön.
Trotz allem.
Ich kann nicht das ganze Leben
mit dunklen Gedanken
und dem Schlechten verbringen.
Zu 90 % ist das Leben schön.
Abgesehen davon lebe ich
mit sehr guten Menschen zusammen.
Ich habe ein sehr gutes Los gezogen.
Trotz allem.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020